with fertile pastural planes productive
Horticulture sectors rugged High Country
and ecologically significant estuaries
the waimakariri district's economy and
character is dependent upon the natural
environment so as we head into the 21st
century it is critical to understand how
environment is changing so we can
prepare find Opportunities adapt and
continue to prosper
climate change is already happening in
the waimaukariri and the district is
about one degree warmer than 100 years
ago
this recent warming has been caused by
an increase in greenhouse gas
concentrations in our atmosphere
these extra gas molecules cause more of
the sun's radiation and heat to be
pushed back down to earth rather than
escaping into space
future changes to temperature rainfall
patterns as well as sea level rise will
have impacts on our communities
businesses and natural environments
when talking about potential climate
Futures in this video we use two
different scenarios of greenhouse gas
concentrations
one is a high range scenario with
greenhouse gas concentrations continue
to rise unabated the other is a moderate
scenario where concentrations stabilize
around 2060.
given we do not know which scenario will
eventuate it's important to examine the
potential changes and impacts associated
with both scenarios so we can fully
understand and explore the risks
greenhouse gases can stay in the
atmosphere for a long time so we're
still likely to see continued climate
change into the future despite efforts
to reduce emissions
foreign
temperature increases could impact Water
Supplies encourage the spread of pests
and place pressure on key growth stages
of some crops
however increased temperatures may also
allow new crops to be grown in the
district and warmer air temperatures
could have other benefits for
agriculture such as reduced stress
experienced by livestock during winter
increasing temperatures in the
waimaukariri district mean that extreme
heat will be more common
the district currently experiences up to
40 hot days per year
this is projected to increase by up to
20 days by the middle of the century
under the moderate scenario
for the high range scenario the average
number of hot days in the district could
triple by the end of the century
there is a large variation in the number
of hot days across the region with more
in the low elevation areas than in the
mountains
the Lee's Valley and Western Plains
could see upwards of 60 additional hot
days per year if future emissions are
unrestricted
the increase in hot days is likely to
place increased heat stress on livestock
contribute to a loss of biodiversity
impact the health of freshwater
ecosystems and lead to increased energy
use for cooling
minimum temperatures are also projected
to warm which will result in fewer frost
and snow days for the waimakarity frosts
are most common for Inland and high
elevation areas of the district but by
the end of the century up to 30 fewer
frosts are projected under the mid-range
scenario with up to 50 fewer frosts
under the high range scenario foreign
District but are generally expected to
increase this occurs in part because as
the planet warms the atmosphere can hold
more moisture leading to more total
annual rainfall in the district
the Eastern and Southern Plains will see
the largest increases in rainfall with
about eight to twelve percent more rain
annually while slight decreases are
projected in the western high elevations
this Ace to waist pattern and the
precipitation changes is fairly
consistent across the seasons except in
Spring which may experience a larger
decrease in rainfall than the other
seasons
residents of the district can also
expect more frequent and severe extreme
rainfall events and storms as the
climate warms during the 21st century
such storms could lead to flooding in
the district's large river systems
disrupt agriculture damage transport
networks and private property
despite a predictive increase in total
rainfall for the district increased
evapotranspiration resulting from warmer
temperatures means that drought is also
expected to be more common and more
severe in the waimakariri this may
impact access to Reliable water supplies
for towns agriculture Horticulture and
the natural environment
a drier and warmer environment is also
likely to experience more wildfire
Coastal land and settlements in the
district could be directly impacted by
sea level rise and Coastal inundation
this will likely increase Coastal
erosion and flooding which could damage
homes and infrastructure such as pipes
and Roads
the newer report contains projections
for many more climatic variables which
you can see here
these climate projections show we may
face significant challenges heading into
the future
reducing our emissions is urgently
needed to stabilize the climate but it
is also vital that we identify
adaptation strategies like strengthening
the reliability of our water supplies
improving biodiversity and River quality
climate change will affect all of us and
the council will need to work in
partnership with
as kaitiaki of the roje we hope open
communication of the science projections
will both motivate and inform
discussions with businesses and The
Wider community
the goal is to have all our community
working together to build resilience and
adapt to climate change
climate change is a challenge that
everyone needs to address from
government through to individuals we all
play a part that's why my career has got
a policy in place and a program of Works
to ensure that we do everything we can
to Future proof our communities against
the challenges that lay ahead the
information in this newer report is
critical to understanding the scale of
the changes that are in front of us
delivering a climate resilient future
needs all regions to take action to
reduce transport emissions improve
building productivity maximize Energy
Efficiency lessen waste and change
consumption habits we're aiming to
improve the council's responsiveness
provide transformational leadership and
take a planned approach to mitigating
and reducing emissions
we're also relying on you as we work
collaboratively with the community and
other stakeholders to adaptively plan
for climate change effects and increase
our resilience it's critical for our
district and its well-being
[Music]